hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice Blitz game that was played
yesterday in chess.com's title Tuesday
it is Hikaru Nakamura versus Magnus
Carlsen and before you guys start
writing that those are not their ratings
they are actually their chess.com
ratings so yes Hikaru is rated 3200 and
the Magnus also 3200 as the the ratings
there are are a bit higher than you
would expect in a regular chess but
aside from that the opening used here is
quite spectacular so Hikaru has the
white pieces and he opens with Ponte A3
like in the grand um uh match uh Adolf
Anderson played against Paul morphy in
1858 uh this game also deserves such a
grand opening and Magnus doesn't reply
with just anything he plays Pawn to G5
and I think um
uh he currently knew that Magnus was
playing all of his games in this
tournament uh using weird moves so
that's why now I think Hikaru challenged
him to a a a a an even weirder game so
A3 Pawn to G5 like I said the Anderson
opening and now point to E4 and uh it is
already now as of move two that we have
a completely new game so no one ever
thought of playing this and Magnus plays
spawned the C5 and if you think about it
it's pretty much like Hikaru played E4
Magnus played C5 so we have the Sicilian
Defense then Hikaru played this very
very offbeat A3 and Magnus played the
extremely aggressive G5 so that's
basically the game that we are having
here so the 4C captures Queen captures
now attacking magnus's Rook here and
Knight to F6 now
uh trying to get the Hikaru to push the
pawn all the way to E5 but this isn't
all that great because then Knight the
C6 attacks the queen and the pawn and
after the queen moves uh then you just
further harass the queen Knight E4 then
the queen will be able to come to A5
with check uh putting pressure on the E5
Pawn so it's nothing good for white so
instead after Knight F6 just Bishop
captures on G5 he curses okay thank you
for the pawn uh it's a weird Sicilian
where I played this slow A3 move bottom
up a pawn so I'm very happy with this so
Knights the C6 Magnus attack is the
queen queen to D3 and now Queen to B6
for this price of one Pawn Magnus is up
in development and currently attacking
the B2 pawn and now you could consider
something like captures captures and
then maybe Queen B5 to offer a queen
trade but hikar just goes back but
Bishop to C1 and defends the B2 Pawn
uh Knight the G4 by Magnus going after a
queen captures on F2 here uh maybe
Hikaru misses it but Knights the H3
Hikaru nicely defends uh D6 and now
Knight to C3 we have knighted G to E5
putting pressure on the queen here and
now as Magnus got some development in
Hikaru says all right now now it's time
to trade the queen to B5 offers the
queen trade and Magnus uh well he could
go back it's not uh it's not really a
position you want to play because uh the
only reason you give up oppon is to be
ahead in development by putting pieces
on their starting squares that's not
really happening so Queen captures on B5
and now Hikaru could go for Knight
captures on B5 and it looks like you
should because you're attacking the C7
Square form uh threatening this nice
Fork the problem is this would only help
Magnus with Bishop captures on H3 and
now it's a very very funny position
where you could play a lot of moves but
the the absolute best is spawn to F4
this is how Hikaru would uh keep his
advantage of the extra Pawn
uh Knight to F3 and now after G captures
and F3 Bishop captures an F1 The Rook
captures you know uh Magnus will play
King to D7 and the game continues with
Hikaru being up upon but having a double
death Pawn so he's still ahead uh it's
nothing nothing spectacular but he he is
definitely ahead and sorry for uh the
board being cropped a little bit in the
previous video or I think it's maybe
even in the previous three videos
um I realized that the first time I did
it but when I'm recording I don't see it
so I forget about it but I fixed it now
so King D7 and um yeah like I said after
Queen captures on B5 uh Hikaru goes for
Bishop captures not Knight captures so
Bishop captures an H3 Magnus ruins he
Pawn structure here G captures and now
just spawn to A6 Bishop back to E2
controlling the Knight on E5 nicely from
uh from E2 and now Knights the D4 Magnus
attack is the bishop and also threatens
Knight captures and C2 check so King D1
uh you will not be castling so it
doesn't really matter Knight characters
that need to uh 9 light captures on E2
and now Rook the C8 putting pressure on
the C file and the Hikaru plays B3 he
wants to play C4
so he no longer has to worry about the C
Pawn so Rook the G8 by Magnus claiming
the open G file for his rook and Bishop
to E3 now we have pawned the B5 by
Magnus here Knight to F3 would be a very
nice idea for Magnus because as long as
Hikaru doesn't push the spawn to F4 you
are very very comfortable here and it's
gonna be very hard to dislodge this
knight from F3 but now after B5 he gives
uh Hikaru a Target Hikaru plays A4 we
have B4 by Magnus so now this is a
backward spawn it's not going to be easy
to defend it but now Hikaru plays a rook
to A2 and although a weird Square for
The Rook you will see that it has many
purposes there but not not right away
first of course we have A5 here we have
E6 and now Rook to A2 we have Bishop to
E7 and Knight the G3 now we have King to
D7 by Magnus
uh the bishop is coming to d8 so he
wants to put pressure on the A5 Pawn
King the E2 and now Bishop to d8 we have
Rook to D1 uh and now we have Rook the
B8 here uh I think Magnus was worried
about Rook to D4 maybe going after the
B4 Pawn or something uh but it's uh it's
a very unpleasant once you move the Rook
no no Bishop to C5 becomes uh an option
putting pressure on B4 and also on D6
but first Hikaru finally dislodges the
Knight Pawn to F4 we have knighted to C6
and now Bishop to C5 attacks the D6 Pawn
so Magnus defends it Bishop to C7 and
now just uh Bishop characters on D6 this
now the sacrifice is merely a trade as
Hikaru will attack the bishop with E5 so
Bishop capture spawn to E5 King C7
Magnuson pins and now e captures on D6
and here we have a remarkable moment in
chess where uh everything you know about
Chess is telling you to play King to D7
when in fact you should play King to da
Magnus played King to D7 and now he's in
a bit of a trouble because now hikar
plays Knight to E4
this threatens Knight to F6 check this
very unpleasant fork and it's hard for
Magnus to make a move of course uh no
chess player will uh now play King 38
and admit the king that King 37 was a
mistake especially not if you are a
world champion even though this should
be played so instead the Magnus goes for
the counter attack Rook to G2 with Chuck
but now Hikaru is completely winning but
you have to figure out how so feel free
to pause the video and win the game for
Hikaru while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
Unstoppable Checkmate and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is King to F3
uh we have to move the king with Tempo
Now The Rook is hanging and the Magnus
has to do something about The Rook the
problem is you don't really have a good
Square for The Rook he does grab the
pawn which means if he's not getting
checkmated at least he grabbed the pawn
he might grab another one so he should
be okay but now comes Knight the C5 with
check King the E8 and here Hikaru played
Rook to G1 and he was in this position
on move 32 that Magnus Carlsen resigned
to the game as there is nothing more to
be done here the problem is uh the
Knight car the Knight covers D7 the pawn
covers E7 and Rook to G8 will be
Checkmate and there's very little you
can do about this to give you an example
if you go for some checks let's say real
captors with checking if two rookies to
checking your phone okay you get rid of
all the checks or even better King to E1
uh now you have to move the king let's
say King to f8 but now comes Knight to
D7 check only square is E8 so King to E8
now Knights the F6 check this guards the
G8 Square so of course King TEF it runs
into Rook to G8 Checkmate and if King to
d8 this is again checked mate as the
pawn covers E7 and C7 in the Knight
covers the D7 Square so that's not
happening and another thing after Rook
to G1 and okay let's say we uh give a
give these few checks you could play F6
to make some reading room for your king
but now Rook the G7 and again what do
you play here uh the D7 is coming so
even if you try to stop this still Pawn
to D7 check and now you either have to
give up The Rook or you move to fate and
not Knight captures an E6 will be a very
nice Checkmate so yeah very nicely done
by Hikaru and even though like I said it
was a pretty pretty wild opening A3 G5
after the the second move E4 and C5 we
were basically playing Sicilian with
this weird continuation A3 G5 which of
course cannot be good for black but it
wasn't a problem Agnes could have played
it but basically it all came down to
this move when akikaru delivered this
check and he should have played King to
d8 and then Knights the E4 no longer
comes with thread so you can play pretty
much whatever you want
a hikar would still be a little bit
better but nothing serious so yeah a
great game by Hikaru beating Magnus like
this with with a move like A3 that's
that's the good stuff and also I believe
Hikaru won the entire event he won title
Tuesday uh and the Magnus although he
joined late and he played weirdly uh you
know in in all of the games he's still
uh achieved a a nice result uh but yeah
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank Frank Brown
Bjorn Bartel Alan winnery
congratulations Dr taco and Francis air
for her contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and I will see you soon continuing to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
such as this one and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and sorry
about the Crooked board in the past few
videos I I really didn't
um uh see it while I was recording see
you soon